société des ordures et des hommes de
Mireille Dumas qui nous fait l'honneur
de participer à Z la Zone d'Éducation en
documentaire merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous et puis vous n'êtes pas venu seul
vous êtes accompagnés
merci beaucoup vous travaillez à la
fonctionnelle on vous voit évidemment
dans ce documentaire merci d'avoir
accepté tous les deux l'invitation de la
classe seconde 10 du lycée Montaigne
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette belle
émission vous avez travaillé avec votre
professeur documentaliste et votre
professeur d'histoire-géo sur ce
documentaire je sais que vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup de questions à poser
mais juste avant de les poser j'aimerais
tout simplement avoir votre ressenti
savoir ce que vous avez pensé de ce film
vous avez le droit de tout dire est-ce
que quelqu'un veut commencer
oui ben moi je trouve qu'il avait très
bien été réalisé et bah qu'on avait mis
en lumière les personnes invisibles qui
avaient le métier d'éboueur par exemple
de nuit ou même de jour et qu'on
considère pas assez du coup bah je
trouvais ça très bien je regarde pas
beaucoup beaucoup de documentaires mais
celui-là m'a vraiment plu et j'ai réussi
à accrocher tout du long donc après
avoir vu ce documentaire c'est vrai que
je faisais plus attention enfin avant je
faisais attention aussi parce que quand
je sortais je voyais les éboueurs du
coup je me disais ah ça a été un travail
difficile et après sur reportage me dit
ah bah quelle fierté un peu et je mets
chaque matin maintenant enfin j'essaie
de leur dire bonjour de sourire avec eux
parce que je me dis voilà ils étaient
invisibles mais maintenant à mes yeux
ils sont plus invisibles ça vous touche
ça
surprend même je suis sûr que vous avez
l'éboueur il est en train de travailler
vous lui dites juste bonjour il a dû se
retourner il a dû se poser la question
est-ce que c'est à moi qu'on me le dit
quoi donc non ça fait très plaisir
quand je descendais à ma mère avec mes
frères et tout je avec mes frères je les
ai dites bonjour au monsieur ils ont dit
bonjour et il était tout souriant il a
fait bon ça fait plaisir est-ce que
est-ce que finalement c'est pas c'est
pas aussi ça le but de ce documentaire
oui oui si déjà si déjà on peut saluer
éviter surtout moi ce qui m'a choqué ce
sont tous ces personnes qui jettent des
papiers au pied au pied justement de des
travailleurs comme ça de la propreté
sans même en disant tiens ramasse enfin
ce que les autres on peut dire c'est ton
boulot ça doit faire ça je te paye pour
ça bien sûr ça c'est absolument c'est
absolument terrible quoi si déjà on peut
prendre conscience de ça et puis
peut-être aussi sur parce que vous êtes
jeune et tout donc les quais de Seine ça
vous concerne j'imagine les fêtes et
tout vous avez vu ce que ça donne au
lendemain c'est c'était une de mes
questions est-ce que ça vous est arrivé
là
d'aller
manger un sandwich boire un coup sur les
quais de Seine on voit des bouteilles
partout c'est enfin un peu quand on
revient le soir on se dit pas que le
matin il y a des personnes qui sont
passées et qui ont nettoyé qui ont fait
tous leurs possibles pour rendre sa
propre quand on revient le soir c'est
ouais comme comme il a été dit dans le
documentaire c'est pire que le matin et
c'est ça chaque jour
on l'entend vous le dites je crois
Jérôme vous dites les gens sont sales
alors je me suis je ma phrase dans le
reportage et elle m'a plu d'ailleurs je
me suis dit tiens les Belges
à Paris aujourd'hui il y a de plus en
plus d'écolos mais ils sont écolos dans
leur tête et pas dans leur gestes c'est
à dire qu'en fait voilà c'est ça on va
on va retrouver Paris ça doit être
propre il y a des gens qui sont payés
pour ça alors on va poser on va laisser
ça va mais ce que vous vous pouvez voir
dans le reportage vous allez quand il
fait beau le matin vers 8h 7h 8h vous
allez vous promet sur les quais de Seine
vous allez voir que c'est c'est un
immond isme et sur tout le long quoi et
sept jours sur 7 vous avez des agents
qui vont passer tous les matins pour
nettoyer tous les matins ils font la
même chose tous les matins Inès moi
j'avais une question concernant le covid
et la pandémie
qu'on connaît en ce moment est-ce que
justement vous avez remarqué peut-être
une prise de conscience ou de la part de
la population au contraire peut-être une
augmentation des déchets ou enfin
qu'est-ce que ça a changé
différents aujourd'hui on a des déchets
différents parce qu'en fait les gens ils
montent dans leur voiture ils prennent
leur masque et ça va par terre et vous
je suis sûr que vous marchez dans la rue
vous regardez vous voyez des masques un
peu partout avant de voir ce
documentaire vous faisiez partie de ces
gens moi la première qui faisait
peut-être pas assez attention vous avez
romane enfin personnellement moi non
parce que j'ai été éduquée très jeune
j'habitais dans le sud de la France et
dès la primaire on nous a emmenés vers
ce qu'ils appellent le SICTOM ouais donc
on nous emmenait on nous a emmené deux
fois donc moi personnellement
et moi en fait je comprends pas comment
on peut retrouver des téléphone portable
des bouteilles plein de d'urines dans
enfin je comprends pas en fait est-ce
que est-ce que ça t'est déjà arrivé
d'interpeller quelqu'un parce que tu le
voyais juste devant toi jeter un mégot
par terre ou un une bouteille vide mégo
non mais je sais que si je des choses
plus grosses oui tu serais capable de
dire excusez-moi
à la montagne des bouteilles que je leur
donnais aux gens Oriane je te voyais
acquiescer tu te sentirais toi capable
de dire ma femme est déjà arrivé oui bah
en fait pareil c'était sur une piste de
ski je vois quelqu'un qui fume déjà ça
me choque un peu mais en plein milieu
d'une piste de ski mais bon et il jette
son mégot par terre donc moi je le
ramasse et je lui dis monsieur Votre
mégot quand même enfin c'est dégueu quoi
et oui bah oui pareil enfin je sais que
pour rebondir à ce que vous avez dit je
sais que moi je jette pas mes déchets
par terre mais des fois si il m'arrive
de faire tomber je sais pas un petit
bout de papier je sais que des fois j'ai
la flemme je me dis oh non quand même ce
que vous vous ne voyez peut-être pas
aujourd'hui que vous voyez pas tout de
suite c'est que tous vos déchets que
vous jetez à droite à gauche vous faites
proliférer des rats et vous avez des
rames et de partout en fait et parce que
un rat est intelligent moi il a mangé
moins il se reproduit plus il a mangé et
puis on va se reproduire et donc en fait
en jetant malgré tout vous êtes en train
de vous
détériorer votre habitat à vous parce
que dans pas longtemps vous allez avoir
des rats qui vont vous allez les voir
même la journée ça va passer de partout
quoi au-delà de tout ça là on parle
vraiment du on va dire des déchets mais
je pense que pour vous enfin l'important
et la réflexion c'est sur le futur
puisque vous vous êtes voilà les futurs
adultes et que la planète vous concerne
or en ce moment bien sûr qu'il y a bien
jeté tout au bon endroit faire le tri
sélectif mais le problème c'est la
surconsommation c'est trop d'emballages
trop de déchets trop de ces 7
surconsommation qui fait que aujourd'hui
là maintenant quand on parle on ne sait
absolument pas où mettre les déchets
vous avez avant nos déchets vous pouvez
quand même le savoir qui sont enfouis
partent à l'étranger enfin etc vous avez
il flotte quelque part sixième continent
voilà sixième continent avant c'était la
Chine qui parfois prenait tous les
déchets toxiques que les autres pays ne
voulaient pas maintenant elle n'en veut
plus et vous avez des endroits un peu
partout sur la planète vous avez des
milliers de tonnes de déchets qui
s'avançait on sait pas du tout ce qu'on
va en faire et ça ça c'est un vrai ça
c'est vraiment un gros gros problème je
crois que ce sont des informations qui
vous parlent vous vous êtes plutôt
éveillés votre génération à toutes ces
problématiques j'imagine je crois
Valentin Valentin Daniel vous aviez des
questions aussi à poser c'était un peu
plus d'un point de vue technique mais
c'était si vous avez eu des des
problèmes un peu sur la réalisation etc
c'est un tournage qui était déjà au
départ uniquement un peu un peu
difficile parce qu'il parce que vous
avez vu comment on rencontre justement
des équipes qui travaillent de nuit de
jour etc donc parfois on a dépassé
vraiment et de loin les 8 heures de
tournage voyez on tournait plutôt à 12
parfois 14 donc s'endormir puis après on
arrivait on dormait mais il fallait
repartir avec une équipe et tout donc on
était pendant quand même deux mois très
très sur le sommeil c'était compliqué
parce qu'on pouvait pas faire juste les
on aurait fait une équipe de nuit on se
sera adapté tandis que l'arbre et ça
bougeait donc de temps en temps on
s'arrêtait pour récupérer ça vous étiez
présente à chaque chaque plan ah bah oui
vous êtes présent à chaque plan puisque
c'est vous qui êtes avec le cadreur donc
Damien qui était qui était avec moi et
qui fait qui a fait cette très belle
image mais bien sûr il faut il faut
concevoir d'abord les aussi toutes les
séquences pour ça qu'il y a je disais il
y a le casting mais en amont vous devez
un peu écrire ce que vous voulez
conséquences du film la première
difficulté c'était ça la deuxième
c'était parce que au travail pour de
bons et à la fonctionné ils ont été
sympa ils ont ils ont mais surtout voilà
ils se sont débrouillés pour venir
parfois un jour où il ne travaillait pas
vous voyez pour inverser etc quand on
veut faire une séquence qu'on a fait de
nuit par exemple des belles séquences de
nuit parce que c'est aussi l'idée c'est
pas faire simplement à reportage là je
sais pas c'est peut-être un peu pointu
pour vous mais il y a une petite
différence entre filmer ce que vous
voyez un reportage et faire un
documentaire
l'idée c'était de faire aussi justement
d'autant qu'on était en plongé dans les
déchets que l'on fait tous il fallait
que l'image soit très belle et moi je
voulais absolument un les sublimer eux
voilà les porter et de rendre compte
aussi de la ville la nuit Paris qui est
absolument magnifique et qui peut être
terrifiante avec les rats aussi bien
Daniel tu avais une question ma question
c'était est-ce que vous trouvez une
certaine
fierté en vous disant que vous protégez
la propreté de la ville de Paris en fait
bien sûr quand j'arrive et que c'est
sale avec avec mes collègues qu'on
nettoie tout après quand on se retourne
et qu'on voit que c'est propre et nickel
bien sûr qu'on a une fierté de notre
travail et puis ensuite on a une autre
fierté dans le sens où alors c'est une
fierté façon de parler mais notre
travail nous on le trouve intéressant et
important parce que déjà aux yeux des
parisiens mais c'est surtout aux yeux
des touristes ce qui va être touristique
étranger ou même des gens qui viennent
du sud de la France et qui viennent à
Paris et ben en fait on veut leur donner
la meilleure image possible de la
capitale et donc la première chose qu'on
regarde quand on arrive quelque part
c'est la propreté alors on essaye nous
de faire notre travail au mieux de
manière à ce que soit propre mais
surtout pour les pour les touristes les
Parisiens et ensuite les gens qui
viennent de province qui viennent à
Paris donc bien sûr c'est c'est j'en
suis fier de quand j'arrive c'est ça dès
que je repars c'est propre
non moi c'était juste pour rebondir par
rapport au préavis que les gens ont sur
le métier d'éboueur enfin vous par
exemple votre travail c'est nettoyer la
ville de Paris le travail du
documentaire si c'est un travail ça
serait plutôt de nettoyer nos mentalités
et tout et qu'on soit beaucoup plus haut
bravo
on la mettra partout sur les réseaux
sociaux ce sera le voilà le lancement de
l'émission comment est-ce que vous avez
fait pour choisir vos lieux de tournage
parce que vous avez juste suivi l'équipe
où est-ce que vous avez spécifique
là déjà c'est de regarder le calendrier
moi j'avais dans la tête quand à partir
du moment où on m'a dit ok on fait ce
film parce qu'il faut la corde à bord
d'une chaîne etc il faut le financer je
me suis dit il faut absolument que je
puisse filmer le 1er mai parce que
c'était remettez-vous l'année dernière
il y avait beaucoup de manifestations de
gilets jaunes il y avait aussi pas mal
de donc de travail pour la fonctionnelle
vous imaginez pour ramasser
ramasser ce qui a été abîmé cassé etc
donc ça c'était un choix et après j'ai
appris ce que je ne savais pas qu'ils
allaient évidemment dans les dans les
camps de
migrants c'était eux qui après que la
police soit passée et fait l'évacuation
aller nettoyer vous l'avez cette
séquence en tête
[Musique]
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était quand même
une scène super touchante on s'imaginait
pas finalement que il y avait toute
toute cette tâches derrière et
oui c'est assez éprouvant comme ça mais
et ça reste en tête oui Myriam
je sais pas j'ai oublié le nom du coup
de la personne qui a dit mais il disait
que oui j'étais en train de nettoyer et
là il y a une petite migrant qui passe
et qui me sourit et je me dis comment
elle peut sourire encore et ça ça m'a
vraiment touché parce que c'est un beau
collègue
dit un peu la même chose par exemple il
était la nuit c'est lui qui travaille
vous savez sous les halles enfin qui qui
dans la séquence du film en tout cas va
aussi nettoyer les squats et je pense
que j'ai remonté peut-être parler du
sentiment que vous ressentez vous aussi
on s'habitue pas à ça parce que parce
que parce que vous rencontrez des gens
avec qui des fois vous parlez dans les
halles et vous comprenez que c'est des
accidents de la vie ils se retrouvent là
en fait ils ont rien demandé mais ils
sont obligés de descendre à cet endroit
là pour pouvoir dormir au sec plus ou
moins avec d'un peu de chaleur et vous
vous rendez compte que ça peut arriver à
tout le monde et cette détresse humaine
là quand la personne vous parle avec ses
mots et que vous vous venez lui prendre
le peu d'affaires qu'il a ça vous fait
mal mais quelque part vous vous êtes là
pour faire un travail donc vous faites
votre travail alors on essaye de bah on
oublie un sac on l'a oublié c'est pas
grave puis et puis mais ça nous arrive
voilà de volontairement laisser des
choses pour la personne alors qu'on doit
tout ramasser
faire
il y a beaucoup de d'endroits variés où
on peut voir les éboueurs parce que
quand on voit des agents de propreté
dehors on se dit que iramase juste des
bouts de papier et jamais on va
s'imaginer qu'ils vont dans de telles
endroits que nous on voit pas en plein
jour et c'est pour ça que la
fonctionnait a été a été créé ce service
là qui est franchement unique au monde
vous le retrouvez nulle part ailleurs ce
service là en fait il est il a été fait
pour justement épauler d'un côté les
arrondissements parce que tous les
agents que vous voyez vous c'est ce que
nous on appelle les agents
d'arrondissement qui font un travail qui
est très difficile parce qu'on se dit il
ramasse juste quelques papiers mais sur
toutes les rues qui fait s'il le fait
pas ça ça s'annonçait et à la fin ça
devient invivable parfois vous mettez
même votre vie en danger par exemple on
a vu avec
les toxicomanes ou ou vous devez
vérifier avant d'entrer sinon après
je vais dire ils peuvent risquer leur
vie
et tout donc bien sûr on faisait la
colline du crack qui a été démantelée
mais on allait on allait une fois ou une
fois par mois on allait nettoyer la
colline du crack et là vous avez toutes
les seringues vous avez tout ça vous
avez les gens qui sont drogués et le
problème c'est que vous êtes en train de
travailler vous il vous passe derrière
il vous passe dans le dos ils sont un
peu à droite à gauche vous avez la
police qui essaye de nous aider mais
c'est pas évident au niveau de la
sécurité et oui physiquement et
physiquement il faut il faut il faut y
aller parce que vous avez des choses à
soulever et mais bon c'est un métier
après c'est après avoir vu ce
documentaire vous êtes dit après tout
c'est un job comme un autre oui Yanis
bah c'est sûr ça fait prendre en
considération de métier mais je vais pas
mentir c'est pas pour autant que j'ai
envie de devenir éboueur pourquoi bah
c'est un travail c'est rébarbatif c'est
long c'est éprouvant physiquement même
peut-être mentalement parce que enfin
tous les jours la même chose au bout
d'un moment bah on commence à en avoir
très vite marre et non c'est pas pour
autant que je ferais le métier mais par
contre je salue les personnes qui le
font ça sans souci moi je me suis dit
que en regardant le documentaire que
finalement c'était pas un métier si
différent que de beaucoup de métiers par
exemple les métiers de en gros moi je
trouve ça aussi chiant que les métiers
j'allais venir parce que en terme de
rébarbatif non la même chose tous les
jours tu sais il y a pas que le métier
des bois finalement qui qui remplissent
ces cases là aussi vous feriez qui
Myriam moi personnellement oui enfin je
ferai pas pour essayer j'aimerais bien
mais je veux dire ils sont vraiment fort
parce que moi je me dis que là par
exemple dans une scène il y a ils
étaient en train de nettoyer il y avait
les voitures derrière et tout moi je me
dis que non je vais pas supporter je
vais j'ai forcément dire un gros mot
parce que ça allait m'énerver déjà que
je n'ai tenté les citoyens les comment
les gens de la ville klaxonne derrière
c'est ça et qu'est-ce que je pourrais
pas supporter en fait le faire oui mais
la reconnaissance surtout c'est ce que
c'est ce qui me marque en fait dans ce
documentaire parce que c'est pas tant la
mission c'est que le manque de
reconnaissance parce que il se tue quand
même à travailler et à rendre la ville
propre le minimum c'est un petit merci
mais les gens ils le font pas ils les
voient surtout pas mais justement enfin
cette fin
documentaire enfin il fait prendre
conscience de beaucoup de choses mais
moi il m'a surtout fait prendre
conscience du fait que les éboueurs
enfin les agents de pauvreté sont pas
sont pas du tout reconnus comme ils
devraient l'être parce qu'ils sont enfin
ils sont en contact direct avec la
saleté et des autres en plus et en
échange enfin ils sont pas ils sont pas
très respectés pas très reconnus et
c'est enfin c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je me verrais pas faire ce
métier et c'est aussi pour ça que je les
respecte vraiment de faire ce métier
quoi Morgane tu voulais rajouter quelque
chose bah déjà je pense que c'est pas
donné à tout le monde parce que on a
besoin d'une force mentale qui qui est
beaucoup plus importante que dans
d'autres métiers mais après oui pour
essayer pendant un stage d'été parce que
tant qu'on n'a pas essayé on peut pas
savoir est-ce que tu voulais poser une
question excuse-moi moi c'est pour un
peu rebondir comment vous gardez cette
force à continuer vous savez que quand
vous allez sur le quai c'est c'est tout
le temps à chaque fois nouveau sale etc
clairement vous gardez cette force
la question
alors c'est le regard des gens qui vont
qui vont porter sur nous qui va qui va
nous aider à tenir et puis ensuite
ensuite il y a quand même une bonne
ambiance en général entre nous et puis
voilà c'est un plaisir après de
travailler avec des collègues de revenir
on sait qu'on va faire la même chose
mais voilà c'est c'est ça c'est puis il
y a des factures à payer donc il faut
travailler quand vous dites qu'il y
avait une bonne ambiance moi justement
quand j'ai regardé le documentaire je me
suis dit
la raison pour laquelle je viendrai au
bout c'est plus pour l'ambiance qui est
entre vous parce que vous avez l'air
très soudé et très euh comment dire
ensemble dans le métier et c'est
important ce côté famille parce que
parce que on va discuter dans la nuit en
travaillant et puis on va se retrouver
dans la journée parce que un tel a
besoin d'un coup de main pour faire
quelque chose donc on est venu plus que
des collègues à la fin devient quelque
part des amis et c'est c'est pas mal
c'est c'est important oui je voulais
vous demander est-ce que vous avez
ressenti le jugement des gens quand vous
étiez avec les éboueurs dans la rue
est-ce que vous avez ressenti un regard
particulier comme ceux que reçoivent les
éboueurs parfois parce que parfois on
était on ne voyait pas on était sur le
côté ou assez loin voyez avec des lampes
focales pour pour filmer de loin etc
donc et vous entendez des réflexions des
petits micro et on a entendu on
entendait des choses bien sûr et on
entend du sur tout le voyez les noms
d'oiseaux qui fusaient surtout au moment
des collectes des des poubelles dans les
quartiers vous voyez quand quand tout à
coup il y a bouchon et là vous entendez
des choses épouvantables épouvantables
[Musique]
blackson va doucement
en général plus les gens klaxonnent et
plus nous en ralenti
si les gens sont derrière klaxonne pas
là on va accélérer on va essayer de
faire au mieux la benne va essayer de se
mettre dans un coin pour laisser passer
les gens au maximum parce que les gens
vous disent oui dépêche-toi moi je
travaille parce que moi en fait je suis
danseuse étoile en fait
très gracieuse
[Rires]
est-ce que le reportage a changé votre
quotidien quand j'ai vu le reportage je
me suis regardé je me suis dit non mais
je me fais pitié quoi c'est pas possible
Jérôme en voyant le reportage et on se
voyant a eu il y a eu une qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire une prise de conscience
en fait je me suis fait pitié tout seul
voilà pour pour parler mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire
quand vous écoutez quelqu'un parler et
vous le regardez et vous vous dites il
fait pitié quoi comme mot sa façon de
parler sa façon de se plaindre on va
dire entre guillemets il fait pitié et
donc j'ai repoussé mes manches je me
suis inscrit au concours de chef
j'ai travaillé travaillé travailler et
j'ai réussi mon concours de chez moi
[Applaudissements]
je me dis peut-être que si je n'avais
pas eu ce reportage là mais je me serais
pas entendu parler je me serais pas
écouté et je serais resté dans mon petit
train-train donc
oui gaillard quand vous vous présentez
qu'on vous demande qu'est-ce que vous
faites dans la vie qu'est-ce que vous
répondez je vais dire que moi je suis
beau après je vais si la personne veut
creuser un peu je vais l'expliquer mon
métier ma spécialisation parce que parce
que c'est je suis boueux je renie pas
mais voilà j'ai un petit truc en plus
qui a fonctionnelle et qui voilà où je
vais je vais avoir un travail qui va
être différent mais sinon non je suis
éboueur je le dis c'est plus pour mes
enfants par contre mes enfants ça me
gêne
expliquez-nous ça voilà je me dis je ne
sais pas ce que font vos parents mais je
me dis quand on est à l'école et qu'on
dit qu'est-ce que font tes parents comme
travail et ben le regard enfin le
le fait que mon fils ou que ma fille
veut dire mon père il est éboueur
quand on est jeune on voit tout de suite
le côté moqueur on va dire et et c'est
ça qui me gênerait le plus en fait par
rapport à mes enfants vous savez ce que
eux disent du coup vous vos enfants
c'est d'abord à la mairie de Paris il y
a la ville de Paris
après éventuellement éventuellement la
propreté à la propreté après à la
fonctionnelle et si ça continue
parce que c'est un beau jeune collègue
oui non mais je fais juste une petite
parenthèse là-dessus c'est pour vous
dire à quel point il faut que les
mentalité change puisqu'on en est encore
à avoir honte parce que c'est ça de dire
que c'est terrible on est éboueurs
je vais aller ailleurs parce que c'est
vrai ça peut paraître chaud
une soirée voilà un 14 juillet il y
avait
vous avez des regrets de l'avoir fait
vous gardez un bon souvenir je pense que
j'en garderai un bon souvenir j'aurais
pas de regrets l'avoir fait parce que
c'est un travail c'est un métier
j'aurais pas de regret avoir fait et
puis je regarderai des bons souvenirs
parce que parce que j'ai fait des choses
aussi qui sont on parle toujours des des
salissures mais quand on fait Solidays
quand on fait tous ces événements là
c'est c'est plaisant quoi en fait on a
la musique il y a des gens c'est festifs
vous ramassez vous nettoyez en même
temps il y a plein de choses et puis
après ça va être les les moments avec
les collègues quand on arrive les fêtes
de fin d'année où on a notre pas de
groupe où on se retrouve qu'entre nous
et qu'on se fait un petit repas de
groupe c'est des des rigolades et c'est
des bons moments il faut pas non plus
exagérer on n'est pas non plus les plus
malheureux et les plus la plus grande
misère de Paris mais
mais non non je regrette pas d'avoir
fait et quelque part je faisais partie
des gens qui parce qu'il faut pas non
plus me prendre pour un sein je faisais
partie des gens qui jetaient avant et
c'est en faisant le métier où je me suis
dit merde à force de nettoyer bah voilà
quoi et donc cette prise de conscience
que moi j'ai eu en étant dans le métier
je je la retranscris à mes enfants et
mes enfants quand ils ont un papier
c'est dans la poche et puis arrivé à la
maison on mettra la poubelle donc non
j'ai pas de regret est-ce que maintenant
dans la rue vous saluerez les éboueurs
c'est important c'est ça qui c'est ça
vous ne manquerez pas de croiser de
croiser Jérôme et tous les autres et
tous les autres merci merci beaucoup on
va s'arrêter là malheureusement
l'émission est déjà terminée merci
beaucoup Mireille Dumas et Jérôme
d'avoir accepté l'invitation de la
classe de la seconde tisse du lycée
Montaigne merci
bravo merci à vous vos questions vos
réflexions c'était vraiment très très
chouette très réussi un petit clin
d'oeil aussi à votre professeur
documentaliste et à votre prof
d'histoire-géo qui nous ont permis de
réaliser cette belle émission on peut
les applaudir aussi c'est très chouette
et puis si vous devant votre écran vous
voulez aussi participer à l'émission
nous poser des questions si vous avez
des commentaires vous n'hésitez pas ça
se passait évidemment sur Internet aussi
# the doc sur Twitter et puis sur la
page Instagram de la chaîne alors à
cause de la situation sanitaire les
premiers numéros de la Zone d'Éducation
documentaire se tourne principalement en
région parisienne mais promis on viendra
vous voir dans vos établissements
scolaires dans vos classes partout en
France métropolitaine et d'outre-mer on
croise les doigts voilà Z revient très
très vite avec une nouvelle classe et un
nouveau film parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge
pour questionner le monde et ces images
allez salut salut
[Musique]